so when it comes to putting ads in a
native app there's actually a lot of
different things we have to consider I
mean especially because the screen size
on a phone or a tablet is a lot smaller
than it might be on a desktop
application so what do we have to keep
in mind there are several things every
app offer a different type of experience
to its users so it's important that your
ad formats match that experience while a
banner ad may work well for a fleshlight
up a gaming app could benefit much more
from a full video ad in other words you
need to take into consideration the
placement within your app and the
different ad formats you could try the
two leading platforms Adsense or
double-click however there are other
platforms out there for you to check out
and we've linked to them in the
instructor notes below